[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sock young
very excited to be talking about Galacta
vism talking about spiritual awakening
we have for the second time rack regime
going us on the show hello Thank You
Ellen thank you so much for coming I
must have done something right the first
time you've had me back oh yeah there
were so many mind-blowing zhh that
happened in the first time we definitely
needed to do number two a major figure
in the global awakening so it's just
such an honor and a pleasure to have you
on for number two there's still so much
to talk about and unpack about your work
for those that don't know racks links
are below and you can explore more our
first episode link is also below where
you can get a big better picture of
things racks a experience a journalist a
film producer he is also a shamanic
facilitator and it's in legal areas like
Peru and he has an upcoming retreat with
AIA
awakenings happening on June 22nd in
2019 the links below for that as well
you can check out his work the eye
awakenings film work as well as the
shamans of the global village film work
that lit those links and information are
below check them out very awakening very
awakening all right piggybacking off of
our first episode of conversation we
spent a lot of time talking about we
find ourselves here on this rock and
humans have evolved and what is our role
why are we here there's 8 billion almost
8 billion of us an hour and then this
exponential technology age it's all
crazy and stuff
what is your synthesis on the current
state what's a jump into the big stuff
huh well look no one really knows I
don't know right but the thing is I feel
and it's really important because so
much of Western culture we've made you
know huge advances in society and
civilization through logical
intellectual understanding of reality
cause and effect science right but
science originally came from alchemy
which is all about more mystical things
as well and there's greater capacity in
the human organism than just the
intellect we've been given intuition
we've been given imagination we've been
given intellect we've been given all
these capacities which do different
things and their ways of knowing that
you don't have to intellectually know so
a lot of my work with the plant
medicines and the earth medicines and
the shamanic
paradigm is really about not knowing
it's about feeling it's about connecting
to what is always being broadcast which
is like the the pattern signal of the
universe right is always being broadcast
but humans essentially in the last
10,000 years of his story right have
fallen into a groove of consciousness
which separates them from what we're in
and that separation has it's not
necessarily a bad thing it's part of I
think a larger world ages and cycle
things which a lot of indigenous
cultures point towards and it's created
a centralization in the specialization
and they say you know the more
specialized a society becomes the more
doomed it is essentially because you
can't adapt to changing circumstances
you get in this one groove and you know
civilizations rise and fall and it looks
like we're in a bit of a civilizational
pickle at the moment you could say and
at the same time there's an equal and
opposite cause and effects of reason
citize ation there's a psychedelic
Renaissance happening there's a global
shamanic resurgence happening there's
this understanding that people feel
distance they've
feel on hold they feel like there's
something more that life should offer
then a little dopamine heat from a
screen as something goes by in your feet
right and we're all feeling this but
it's like we're addicted to civilization
yeah and the thing that we forget is
that these 10,000 years of his story
have been ever expansional exponentially
tightening Geyer of history which has
centralized and specialized and narrowed
down and I think there's a culmination
point to that but at the at the deficit
of opening up and connecting and feeling
so so much of these shamanic medicines
and this I this buzzword of awakening
right what is that right it's it's like
some brand lifestyle thing that
capitalism is absorbing the psychedelics
and the shaman isms at the same time as
they are potentially healing and
cleansing us and reconnecting us to the
thing that we're in so to answer your
question what is it why are we here I do
have some ideas but I don't know but
they come from an intuitive response
it's like an immune response signal from
the planet through humans trying to wake
us up and trying to bring us back into
relationship with the planet yeah yeah
oh man that was so jam-packed with
awesomeness okay so let's start with the
groove that's been kind of that we're
itching it's like the the the we're
going as deep as the Grand Canyon right
now is how it's what it feels like with
the way that we're disconnected from
Mother Earth from Gaia from this
planetary energy that we have with the
plants and animals insects and and and
the that groove that we've dug ourselves
into has has that's why we feel like the
immune system of Earth is trying to
shake and awake well note number one the
myth you know I would hazard a guess
that the the average person if there's
such a thing is so caught up in the rat
race in the 95 and the survival based
chakras survival mechanism the
capitalism has
you know separated reduced and conquered
us to in this global battery farm on
planet earth that it there's not a lot
of time to to tune in to feel and if you
have training in feel you feel exhausted
you feel overwhelmed you feel oppressed
you feel like everything's hitting the
fan everywhere you look in the world
these uprisings of everything happening
the climate everything seems pretty dark
and it's like how do you how do you have
faith or hope or anything unless you
tune into spirit and see you know nature
is intelligent nature is miraculous it
is a miracle the gift of life we forget
we wake up and we be gradually get on
the public transport and go to work and
it's like having a shitty Wednesday it's
like dude you're in the miracle of life
but we've forgotten how desensitized
have we become right
how denatured it's like and you know the
culture is not nurturing that so there's
this cause and effect that we are so
distant from the earth and that
tightening Geyer of history we've gone
through I mean it's it's sort of like a
domino effect if you look at history
basically starts with you know
domestication of Agriculture and cattle
and things like that and this hoarding
of nature to protect us it this concept
of time that we start to realize oh this
tomorrow we better start thinking about
tomorrow and then what's gone before and
there's this consciousness which
bifurcates and it basically falls out of
the moment so you know the popularity of
Eckhart Tolle and the power of now and
this meme of trying to bring us back
into the being here now is so important
because this is what indigenous cultures
essentially even though in the last
10,000 years they have also husbandry
and agriculture as well but they also
have a connection to the land and an
understanding of rhythms and you know
they did have to get the harvest and the
crop ready for the next season but
that's where civilization started so it
started with this separation from I
guess more nomadic culture or you know
whatever it was before but there's
there's still land based culture and
indigenous culture the riches of the
earth and the technologies of the earth
and we've improved our lot but at the
expense of our connection
to the earth so you know as we've gone
through history and we're building
empires and civilizations essentially I
mean there's a lot of prehistory you
look at authors and anthropologists like
Graham Hancock and ones who point out
pyramids are on ley line energies of the
planet and a lot of indigenous cultures
understand the energetic grids of the
planet that the Pachamama as they say in
South America and Mesoamerica is a
living organism and we're embedded
within it and it's about reciprocal
relationship with the planet but
essentially you know Western culture at
least from the Industrial Revolution on
has become mechanistic and has become
sort of product orientated and results
orientated that it's it's about what we
can take and what we can make but it's
not about relationship it's an abusive
relationship with planet Earth right so
you know that's the the general drift of
history has culminated in this but we
know that nature post-industrial
revolution is really the yeah place when
does the revolution yeah okay yeah and
and whenever I play indigenous music
here and just close my eyes or just
dance to the indigenous music it really
feels like I am setting the clock back
in time to when there was a deeper more
harmonious connection to how we felt the
earth and the structures we built and
how we communed with it in a non
extractive way this is the key thing so
a lot of the indigenous music in Peru
they have these sacred songs called eco
rose right and they're essentially
they're not your normal music it doesn't
matter what words they put to them it's
about the rhythms of the sound because
we know I see in my feed the other day
it's like oh the hippies are right it's
all about vibrations right it's a
vibration and we're getting to the level
of technology which is getting going
back to mysticism and understanding that
everything is vibration everything the
table is vibrating is vibrating a
different level so in Peru in the in the
ayahuasca traditions ayahuasca
essentially opens up your energetic
being it's a healing plant medicine
there can be purged of effects there can
be visions but essentially it's
activating your vibratory field so you
know I'm not even sure in the West if we
understand
that so many indigenous cultures live in
Chinese medicine and other indigenous
cultures they understand that we have
different gradiated bodies we have an
energetic body we have an emotional body
we have a physical body and we can even
just activate that vibratory field by
going
[Music]
and just like that you can just activate
and it feels you can drop into the
moment and you're shifting around your
energetic body so so much of Western
culture is like it's like it's got a
sweet and it's it's it's all concerned
about the rapper but it's not concerned
about what the the substance is on the
inside the rapper is kind of like what
you're showing everyone into the world
essentially right interesting so the
rapper that's such an Akula put it and
then the what we're not we're not as
concerned about the inside which is this
this unlocking of the inner self work
and the connection to earth well you
know what we are the clothes that the
universe wears right we are the
manifestation because we still see see
ourselves is Here I am in the center of
the world or the universe I'm looking
out through my perspective of egoic
consciousness which is a gift and a
blessing and part of the miracle but
it's how can we at this stage of history
how can we relearn to let that ego find
right relationship and going to the back
seat versus being this driving force
which dominates the planet takes from it
and destroys it so to finish off the
entire thing essentially it's all
vibration and their songs aren't just
normal songs we know that sound has his
power all the old eldritch alchemical
sort of energy in songs it changes your
consciousness Plato even said be we're
changing to a new form of music because
it changes the consciousness right and
different world ages we look a few
hundred years ago we have classical
music which I listen to in the car quite
a lot now it's so calming and you listen
to techno music it's gonna up your music
but you listen to pop music is the pop
music from the 80s it takes you back to
that vibrational frequency of the
zeitgeist at the time and you feel a
certain dopamine hitting you feel-good
music affects our energy in our
consciousness dress so the Peruvian
music with acai rose and ayahuasca songs
they're not just normal music there are
actually vibrational codes which are
essentially the vibrational imprint of
certain plants so on ayahuasca it opens
up the energetic field and the shaman
the curandero as they call them in Peru
the the healer the medicine man or woman
so it karai is song ocurro
ocurro is song and the curandera
here in Sderot from the spanish to cure
or to heal yeah
is the medicine person is this what we
call the shaman which is a Western
conceived in the whole nother story
okay medicine person so they open up an
ayahuasca I was compared together
usually the song plus healer well this
is the thing again the the capitalist
marketplace is absorbing psychedelics
and shamanic experiences as another peak
experience but it's so it's like an
iceberg with 9/10 under the water
there's so much more than just the big
experience it's all about relationship
so the music of the song the akaru
is essentially the vibratory codes of
different plants so the shaman will sing
the song and the vibrational code which
is like a vibrational code of let's say
aho sucha
which is in the garlic family and one of
the master plants in peru and the spirit
of aho such are in the plant is a
vibration so if you sing the vibration
you're singing the energy of that plant
into the person in ceremony deriving the
ceremony specific ikura to each plant
how does how do they figure that they
learn them so the thing is here's the
thing in Peru what they understand that
the the medicine people the curanderos
they trained from an early age there's
potential ways to become a shamanic
person and again in the West this
commodification of the shaman meme is
dangerous and it's really glamorized
when you know I will get to this in a
minute but also stand in Mexico doing
episode to a shamans in the global
village with the indigenous mera kaam a
that which whole nation and they work
with peyote it is arduous it is hard
work and you are that the medicine
person is in service to the community
and to the planet and it's never ending
because you have to be responsible for
the energies of the people so even
within the capitalist commodification of
the ayahuasca lodge system in Peru
they're still clients and they're still
people the car pilgrims are come seekers
to experience ayahuasca and the
curandero is in charge of the ceremony
so we think it's just ayahuasca it's not
just the ayahuasca it's the set and
setting of being in a focus space of
it's usually in a melaka in the ceremony
space and it's a ceremony it's a
hospital
it's psychotherapy yes it's healing its
visionary it's not just one thing it's
the iceberg it's so many it's
reconnecting and so the healing happens
when the songs are sung
guide the ceremony and steer the
ceremony and you re sensitize so science
has done some research with EEG
electroencephalography scans and MRI
machines in the last decade legal tests
on psychedelics and entheogens these
shamanic sacraments and they know they
studied psilocybin ayahuasca and LSD and
amongst others maybe some five em you
know as well and essentially
psychoactive substances affect the brain
pretty much the same area but slightly
different tweaks with the different
substances called the default mode
Network and the default mode Network is
like this regional nodal cluster that
keeps us in this reality Channel right
so in Western culture where basically
mono phasic we think okay this is it
this is reality let's go get drunk let's
go get stoned but this is it
right we we exist in this bandwidth of
reality and we just go a little bit
around it to calm down or to speed up
right indigenous cultures are basically
polyphasic which means they understand
there's not just waking consciousness or
dreaming consciousness there's all these
levels of consciousness which are all
there like a spectrum of color there's
no can tune into that you can train in
channels so you know Western cultures
like red in the rainbow and that's it
it just gets one one band of the
spectrum of consciousness and what I see
happening in this you know 70 year
journey of psychedelic Renaissance
reclamation in the West is this is this
reabsorption and re empowerment of the
fact that it's not only okay to change
your consciousness it's actually
necessary to realize what your embedded
in otherwise we're just in this
post-industrial wonder if I'm in
consciousness right you're we're just in
the red we're just in the red where
there's a whole rainbow out there right
and in the ER you're explaining this in
a you know the the default mode Network
keeps us in the red and dissolving the
default mode Network through some of the
Earth's medicines I still have
psychoactives enable us to go to the
blue the green the yellow the orange and
this is and what are
some of these channels like right yeah
so the default mode Network keeps us in
that channel of consciousness and when
it's lowered essentially the egoic
consciousness which is focused and has
created the drive of history right
so essentially shamanic psychedelic
plant earth-based medicines are the
antidote to history right because
history can I swear it's [ __ ] us up
right is it it's completely [ __ ] us up
and it's like we've forgotten what we're
in right so as the default mode Network
lowers we open up to the other channels
of reality they're always there that
indigenous cultures as caretakers of the
medicines understand so within the
ceremony of ayahuasca and the Eco rose
and the singing it's not just the the
medicine of ayahuasca activating
lowering default mode Network
it's the ceremony it's the ritual and
it's the guidance of a medicine person
who understands what we're in and it's
been bridging and keeping that
connection so as we do this the question
is will then what happens right so we
start to realize activism happens if you
feel the application of what you're
you're learning so but what we do is we
realize we're in something bigger so
it's almost as if you know I quote the
poet Rumi a lot he says like the drop
rejoins the ocean we're embedded in an
interconnected alive intelligence living
miracle called you know the unity field
the planet the universe the galaxy
I mean it's all I love it when you see
you know the comparisons between the
neuronal structures of synaptic pathways
of the brain and the galactic structures
of the galaxies right there as above so
below and this is the thing nature
doesn't just change the rules for earth
and all the other spaces it you know
there may be some peda bation of physics
and different areas of the universe but
essentially the same rhythms and the
same lessons so when we're trying to
figure out what do we know well what I
can ensure and glean from shamanic
connection to these spaces is that
nature works on the same principles
across the board in that spectrum so
essentially what I understand is in the
shamanic paradigm there's the baseline
reality right
then there's essentially an astral
ecology which is like you know it's like
everything's giving up if you could wear
infrared goggles or something and you
can see the heat signatures being given
off so imagine the planet gives off
these heat signatures which are actually
the energetic emanations of the physical
form so there's a whole like if you go
to the bottom of the sea and there's
this whole world down there that
scientist is discovering these bizarre
creatures that we never thought could
exist in there so alien from what we
hear on the surface in the shamanic
paradigm there's this dimension of
reality which I think there is a
geography to this so say a baseline
reality and there's an energetic ecology
like an envelope around the earth in two
high dimensions and you can you know you
can you can pull on the quantum physics
in my concentric circles a little bit
yeah but the thing is you're Monsieur
Kaku world famous physicist who did the
book hyperspace is potentially 12 hyper
dimensions or more you know whatever
there's but even science is coming
around to the understanding that there's
dimensionality to you and this is
essentially what the indigenous paradigm
with with plant medicines have been
saying so within that first envelope and
you know the earth itself if you look at
just a biological understanding of the
earth it's the physicalness of the earth
and there's all the systems in place as
it's it's pumping life around the earth
but as you go up into the atmosphere
there's all these invisible levels of
energetic reality like the magnetosphere
they ionosphere the lithosphere which
filter and block out deadly UV rays from
the Sun to make life on Earth possible
it's a living organism this is not a
metaphor right we're embedded in a
living organism so my current little
riff which I really like it's like I've
been really getting into research on the
stomach biome so as a default mode again
work essentially we have older networks
of consciousness the intellectual egoic
consciousness which is both in the
default mode Network and the frontal
lobes parietal lobe which some medicines
like five Meo
lower that sense of egoic individuality
and we rejoin that unity field of source
consciousness there's also the stutter
that the the heart which has 70 percent
neuronal cells like the brain the same
cell Sabrina Mae
are in the heart and this feels and so
we're talking that it's not about
intellectual egoic knowledge and feeling
right the feeling body is located not
just physically in the heart it's
actually you know the electromagnetic
field that is generated by the heart is
creating that ability to connect and so
when you fall in love with someone
it's action at a distance your your
consciousness is affected by someone at
a distance yes science can start to
understand and if they get biometric
readings yes the heart math Institute's
been doing you know readings on that
there's also then the stomach the biome
which is so old which he's the thing yes
so this consciousness they had
intellectual consciousness is the latest
like a layer of the network million
years in comparison to I well I think
you know whatever maybe fifty thousand
years or so of language egoic
intellectual consciousness and the thing
is we have survived the species before
we had this before we had language
before he had art before we had what we
think of is the modern human
we had other ways not just to survive
but to thrive and to be in relationship
with the planet so the stomach biome has
seven trillion microorganisms right that
interestingly enough go in and out of
flashes of gamma consciousness so the
same consciousness that can occur in the
brain here on psychedelics antigens
definitely five Meo
actually is what it's and gamma is a
frequency you know hertz vibrational
frequency again electromagnetic
frequency of unity so the thing is they
say you have a thought about a third of
a second before you think it so the
brain is this receiver of consciousness
and a lot of our gut instinct and our
our decision-making happens down here
we're like not not gonna go near that
person i want that or whatever and this
brain is an older network so when this
egoic consciousness lowers down which is
what psychedelics do right these
networks can receive the information
which are always being broadcast and
connect us to the planet into the source
into these different levels of that
rainbow of full spectrum consciousness
so the astral ecology is potentially
inhabited i I don't know
one way or the other and if you're into
shamanic work at all there's you know
things like ayahuasca or a very
visionary and people say well how can I
be imagining these jeweled labyrinths
you know crystalline cities and alien
entities things I don't know but you
know what I do know is that um
dimethyltryptamine which is in the
ayahuasca brews usually is also in our
brain and essentially when we're
changing our consciousness with these
plant and earth medicines we're opening
up and it's it's it's taking us to a
conscious awareness of these thresholds
of reality in the spectrum and the full
spectrum of consciousness and in that
full spectrum like dimethyltryptamine is
all through the plant kingdom and it's
all through the insects so one of the
common motifs of alien encounters on DMT
is the man toid insectoid you know
things but I keep thinking what if
they've got DMT and deemed to you know
Rick Strassman wrote the book DMT the
spirit molecule and did these legal
tests with dimethyltryptamine in the in
the 90s and there was a documentary as
well they think that potentially it's
the gatekeeper neurochemical which takes
us into the Dreaming each night and also
mediates those peak experiences of birth
death and near-death experiences but
what is if the plant kingdoms got it and
in the indigenous peruvian understanding
and pretty much all around the world
medicine people understand that we're
not the only intelligent species we're
just the most ago ik right and the thing
is all of these plants have
dimethyltryptamine like we do but
they're in that space all the time right
where to egoic lee focused and going
through here but the greatest wisdom on
the earth is probably a clump of redwood
trees you know a few miles wide that's
been hundreds of years old in concert
and relationship with the earth and in
putting the signal always being
broadcast and doing its job to release
oxygen so we can breathe it because all
the species rely on one another right so
damn that was so profound that a clump
of redwood trees and the
interconnectedness of all the organisms
that it deals with in the root systems
and deals with in the in the in the in
the
in the atmosphere and in the in the
insects and animals well that is the
most wise that is the most aware that is
the most connected we you know what if
you look at geology or different you
know Earth Sciences like that there's
the mineral Kingdom right then there's
the the plant kingdom and the plants
essentially and the animal kingdom
there's a process at work in nature
which she creates new species and
there's an interdependence and like this
you know holographic jigsaw puzzle
across space-time which is life right
and they all work with one another so as
we go into that energetic ecology this
to finish off that train of thought
there's potentially those species so
it's almost as if I feel that if you
smoked DMT or do ayahuasca it's taking
you to that frequency of reality that
the energetic signatures of potentially
the terrestrial organisms have an
energetic shadow or reality - and you're
almost gate-crashing hyperspace it's
like you know the insects like oh this
the humans again let's get rid of them
it's like there's a there's an
interdependence existence right and
we're almost colonial in our approach to
hyperspace or to the shamanic realms or
where it's taking us - because we keep
thinking it's all about us but all these
creatures are holy
all these creatures are alive and all of
them are emanations of the planet they
had the M team the mammals insects the
plants etc and as you go further up the
band width of that rainbow of
interdimensional inner space you go away
from duality and away from that
vibration settling down you know so we
mentioned on before in the Eastern you
know traditions of the Vedic traditions
they understand that in the beginning
you know in the in the in the Catholic
theology in the Christian felt theology
and probably the Jewish stay say in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
God in the Word was with God in the
Eastern traditions they say essentially
the the originating vibration was the
arm the sounds the emanation of the
sound and as that vibration settles and
condensates it essentially becomes
denser until it becomes matter and
becomes the baseline world right and I
think physics would agree with this
essentially that's what you know you go
all the way up to super string theory
it's all vibration all the way up and
the further you go up the more intense
and the more higher the vibration until
it becomes that white light oceanic
source consciousness which some people
like to call God in that home and that
away from duality are together and then
the matter is what is closest to so well
here's the thing everything is vibration
but there's also this originating
vibration it's like when you drop a
stone into a pond and it drops and it
creates the ripples and then the ripples
come back and intersect and intersect
that is the holographic universe the
simulation it's created from the
interference patterns of the rippling of
the original vibration
according to ancient cultures right my
interpretation of them so we're
relearning at this point in history this
relationship that were not who we think
we are we're not just the intellectual
minds yes--and mediated through many
ways I mean I like to read my heart
brain but and it's about the it's about
the integration of the three those three
things the the energy body the emotional
body in the physical body or the the
mind the heart and the gut and so the
gut instincts you know they've just done
so much research with the stomach biome
and realized that these seven tree and
microorganisms are essentially keeping
us alive we can't live without them
right yes and sometimes though they go
off and they crave sugars there's this
there's this phenomenon CAM interplay
that you were describing earlier was
mind-blowing that that's occurring well
this is what I love is like not many
people and unlike them guests on your
show do we get little fragments of the
whole but when you start to this go
top-heavy and look at the big picture
and do things like this it's it's a
miracle and it makes sense it
interconnects and it's all one big story
that's conjugating itself right so the
the stomach biome essentially they've
just recently in the last two months
discovered they thought the brain was
sealed off from bacteria but they
discovered that it has its own biome in
the brain and the vagus nerve connects
from the biome in the stomach all the
way up to the brain and it feeds it so
they're thinking now the
pression some psychiatric conditions all
these things are calls from imbalances
in the biome and stimulating the vagus
nerve can solve so many of those exactly
and again the the biome you know it's
made up of these seven trillion
microorganisms so if we were to
sterilize them and to kill them off we
wouldn't be able to process our foods
and break them down and we would die so
we are actually a colony organism we
think we're an individual right but we
are a collection of seven trillion
microorganisms that we need to survive
and in the same way as you see this in
microcosm in us then start to extend
that metaphor to the planet to what they
call in the Mesoamerican traditions
Pachamama yes well James Lovelock who
worked for NASA in the seventies and
famously coined the term the Gaia
hypothesis after the Greek goddess of
the earth this idea and I call it whole
systems theory now to keep it
politically correct it's it's basically
the idea that the planet is a living
organism yes yes yes shock horror that's
what the indigenous people have been
saying for millennia yeah yeah and it's
only since the post-industrial
revolution that we've we've had such a
filtered and removed consciousness
essentially you know the fall into
history is a sickness it's like at one
stage where I'm from in Australia the
indigenous people the Australian
Aborigines basically have this phrase
that we translate to dream time
consciousness this understanding that
the the original people that go back
80,000 years and I think that maybe even
doubly so now who didn't fall into a
narrow bandwith of consciousness that
writes it all down they stayed in this
consciousness connected to the earth
nomadic on the earth because here's the
thing
the body and the DNA is designed not
just to lease versions getting rid of so
much of that culture and that's such a
problem because we need to preserve some
of the lineage that has been doing it
through their entire lifetimes and
passing it on when you're preservative
we we need the mature perspective as a
planetary civilization to listen to the
elders to listen to the indigenous
communities who are very very
worried that [ __ ] is hitting the fan in
the energetic ecology of the planet
right so the Aborigines who go back all
that time they stayed in this dream time
consciousness of interconnectedness of
reciprocation of understanding modern
science tells us that the DNA is not
static it's not inert it's not dead it
is a living it's designed to evolve
constantly to adapt to the conditions on
earth that fortunate unless you end up
on a cubicle for 40 years of your life
and then get a little watch at the end
of you if you're if you're just living
in a box and you're not getting the air
you're not getting the Sun and the
vitamin D it's it's mind-boggling the
way nature is so interconnected so when
sunlight hits the I know ninety percent
of our time is now spent indoors I know
and 50 percent of the civilization now
lives in cities in boxes in these
archipelagos which are bad for our
health because they're not on the earth
that it's so sunlight comes into our
eyes converts to vitamin D creates
melatonin Milutin which is a tryptamine
skin pigment cascades and starts a whole
biological process and yet it's too cool
and groovy to wear sunglasses you're not
getting like everything about modern
culture is killing us right and we don't
get it because we don't see the
interconnected web of life and in all
the trash goes to the landfills that
gets buried in I know so you know the
the estrella aboriginals understood that
we're in we're in we're in a mythic
relationship with the planet the planets
alive and this is Gaia hypothesis and
James Lovelock thing in the 60s there
were these hippies bare Owsley who is
the the acid chemist who pretty much
made the bulk of acid in the Haight
Ashbury who kick-started the psychedelic
revolution he came up with this theory
that also Jerrod heard one of the other
poets and mystics of the 60s as well
promulgated this idea that it's almost
like the Gaia hypothesis that the planet
right as a whole organism is always
regulating itself it's always shifting
changing feeding energy around energies
never created or destroyed one species
dies another one brings up because the
energy is distributed around right and
so they had this idea that coin which
turns McKenna in the eighties nineties
took up as well that the planet as a
living organism
secretes I love that woods because it's
a secretion right it's about it like a
bodily fluid she secretes psychoactive
plants and materials including humans
because we're psychoactive yes and
animals that they have the demo
dimethyltryptamine right it's like these
psychoactive substances are the
neurological basis for the energetic
connection to these realms but there's a
there's a part later it's like God's
backdoor access right and so the idea
was these substances which we may say
ayahuasca San Pedro
Morning Glory seeds acacia DMT is the
before various toad whatever humans
they're created by the planet and
secreted because she wants the species
to communicate with each other right so
here's the thing we think in the in the
in the war on drugs mentality you're
just getting higher but actually what
you're doing is with the right
relationship with the right set and
setting with the right container of
ceremony which is so important to
respect the earth and to show the
humbleness in your reconnection like a
child relearning from the mother from
Earth our relationship with the earth it
can engender an environment where you
can reconnect to these psychoactive
substances as the key to open your lock
being secreted being secreted
specifically because we are meant to
engage with them yes so one of the
greatest ironies oneness the oneness so
one of the greatest ironies of you know
20th century sort of war on drugs
mentalities why take a psychoactive
substance from the earth or from a lab
you know from the earth and it's like oh
it's like it's at the left hand path
it's like chasing the easy way well
these substances are not easy they
demand a lot from you a lot of them are
purgatives in fact the the great
popularity of ayahuasca is not just
because of the visionary component it's
because it cleans us out and it restores
us to our default node settings to God's
factory reset to this energy body which
is you know we store we store trauma we
store stress you know energy body in our
emotional body and it manifests as
sickness in our physical body so you
know you can actually cure physical
things by removing
root-cause in the in the subtle energy
body of the system which is what these
medicines assist with and when you do
that in that wholeness in that oneness
you reconnect to the greater web of life
to the mother to Pachamama who welcomes
you back into the astral garden right
and you remember that you're not alone
that you're an emanation of a greater
thing and this has been the separation
so history is only ten twelve thousand
years old and I feel what happened the
Australian Aborigine as I said before
they understand that there's this
potential for what we call dream time
consciousness for pretty much every
indigenous culture on the planet has an
understanding of cyclic time there's
golden ages silver ages bronze ages kali
yuga 'he's a fall of consciousness so
the the judeo-christian ik bibles and
their religions and their mythologies
often point to a deluge or a flood or
they point to a fall of consciousness so
we are in ongoingly these climactic
upheavals in larger scales of time like
humans are potentially millions of years
old and we have survived but there's
world ages and these indigenous cultures
have been custodians not just of of
entheogenic medicines but of the
knowledge of what has gone before and
they point to the fact that there's ages
where ice ages come and then floods come
when they melt and then there's a great
you know time when civilization
flourishes and then it goes around in a
cycle again because the planet is alive
and she's growing so my analogy is until
they get off the rock and then that's
potentially well this is this mother
earth is like a womb it's it's it's a
galactic womb right it's the the most
ridiculous statistical abnormality that
life could exist on this planet which
goes all the way up as I mentioned
before into the upper atmosphere
filtering out the deadly radiation and
there's energetic relationships with a
magnetic field of Earth to Venus and
Mercury and to the Sun and the Sun
intergalactic Sun and as I said before
those galactic synaptic pathways where
you see it looks like they look like
brain structures or synaptic pathways on
the galactic level so when I described
the the rainbow bandra connectedness of
the celestial bodies yeah it's like you
know the
they're not nothing is separate all
these ones so source consciousness which
shocks us that vibration comes down and
manifests everything is the one big
thing manifesting so if we could shrink
down and go into the stomach biome and
look at would be like Park we're in
something right it's like think about 17
microorganisms 7 billion humans on the
planet it's almost as if we are one
strand in the planetary biome mm-hmm
right and we're not alone all the
species are other strands in the biome
and we know through prebiotics and
probiotics that sometimes they go off
and there's good ones and there's bad
ones so we describe this whole drift of
civilization how we're boxed and
compartmentalize and we're not open to
the wind and the light and we're not
getting fed we're not optimal we're not
this is this whole Drive in Silicon
Valley for optimizing human beings get
back to nature
that's what optimizes us right by being
in relationship with nature and the DNA
hears and feels and adapts and creates a
flush and cleansers and you know yes
like there's no as it's like where one
strand in the planetary biome and we're
meant to interact so there's this thing
there's a very interesting thing where
they've had this a single toxic
plasmosis and there's a strand of
bacteria which infects and passes on and
cats get it right and when cats get it
the bacteria makes oh no sorry the mice
get it and when mice get it it makes
them give themselves up to the cat so
the bacteria can spread to the cats
across the species lines and so it
drives an organism to do something which
is fatal but it's in it's in in the
interest of the thing driving it which
are these microorganisms right which
have their own agenda so think of it in
humans where denuded we've we've you
know we've ruined our microbiome and
it's like where we've gone off we've
been craving sugars and we're out of
control and in the planetary biome look
at what it's done huge open crevasses of
mining taking the uranium taking the
precious metals taking you know taking
from the mother and the earth and
building great technology things from
them sure but because our intellectual
consciousness doesn't understand the
relationship it's great to have you
latest iPhone and the planets about to
go through a death knell or at least a
transformation right it's like we're all
going down with our latest iOS it's not
gonna save us right that week there is a
reason for because in the cyclic time we
fall out of unity consciousness into
point consciousness we create all these
amazing technologies now it's just
thinking the other day I was coming back
from Mexico imagine if we can harness
the biomimicry of advanced science to
you know do the solar in the wind and to
do vibrational technology whatever the
most advanced things are which are
ecological sustainable and we can embed
them back into civilization to go back
into relationship with the earth if we
marry the spirit and the science yes
then we can create a new golden age but
otherwise it's going to hit the fan and
it's doing it very quickly so as the
mouse gives itself up to the cat humans
have been doing the same in the planet
we've been driven to this species
extinction level and we're going through
what what scientists say is the sixth
great species extinction on the planet
that's happened many times before yes
yes we're going through increased global
warming which is definitely contributed
to by man-made fossil fuels and as NASA
agrees is actually happening on every
planet in this solar system as deeper
galactic energies cosmic rays are coming
in astrophysics not even hippie-dippie
[ __ ] astrophysics tells us that cloud
cover and the weather is actually
controlled by cosmic rays that again we
keep thinking through these blinkers
that it's all about us and it's all
about even just the earth is one little
crater of humanity but we're
interconnected and it went the energy
coming coming from we crossed over the
elliptic of the middle path of the
galaxy back in 2012 and so we're now
getting bombarded by deep cosmic
radiations we used to be in a little
backwater and safe and there's these
things called magnetized which are a
hundred thousand times more power from
the Sun every second bombarding this you
know in the intergalactic neuronal
structure that's connecting energy and
feeding it through the larger cosmic
ecology we're getting it's like building
to orgasm so I say the sun's like
basically having a Sun gasm
and the planet is feeling it the earth
because it's in relationship with the
Sun and all the energy is building and
everything's coming and everyone's like
freaking out and massacring all solar
flare ejections and cosmic rays and it's
like what is this [ __ ] it's a process
which has been underway and continually
happens over larger tracts of time so as
well as the global warming scientists
totally agree that we are on the cusp of
the new ice age winter is coming right
and the thing is there is potentially a
process of how the global warming and
the climate change is the kickstart to
the ice age in those larger tracks of
time so we had this potential as this
species to come back to Center to come
back to a relationship with the earth
because it's not separate from us and
it's almost as if psychoactives and
shamanic medicines are the prebiotics
and the probiotics cleaning us out to
reveal that we are the medicine as well
and that we can connect so these
accretions of the earth me as you just
came back from Mexico in studying and
further trying to turn into film for
people to better understand how to do so
we have awesome images for you to talk
about this process of Awakening and how
you're inspiring the people in this well
all of it is the process of reengagement
all of that that's what it's really
about re-engaging with the planet which
secretes the psychoactives which are
like keys to the locks of our
consciousness which if it wasn't meant
to happen it wouldn't work it wouldn't
fit and all these indigenous cultures
who were caretakers of the medicine like
peyote with through which old people of
within Mexico last week they understand
that their caretakers and they're in
relationship it's like humans are the
little brother right and the plant
kingdom is older they're the older
brothers and on baja in the bot in the
planetary biome the planet is trying to
bring us back into regulation and to get
rid of all those sugars and all the
cravings which have resulted in the
civilizational almost collapse we're at
and the way to do that is through re
engaging with the planet and it's
basically the consciousness which is so
distanced from the understanding of what
we're connected to that thinks taking a
psychoactive material is outside of
yourself remember how there's the
microbiome in the gut we can't live
without but we don't see them we don't
realize
we are that in the planet and we're
connected to the planet and the planet
is regulating herself she's shifting and
changing and going through galactic
puberty right and we're all part of that
you know that's specie secretion so when
you see different species they're not
just done Winnie and in competition with
each other they're actually in
cooperation when you step up a level and
look at the network centric
understanding of nature she works
through multiple avenues at the same
time to make things happen so bees
collect the pollen from the flowers and
spread the pollen so the you know
there's this huge global catastrophe
with the bees dying off and they're like
well if that goes down essentially the
food chain goes down do you see how its
interconnected here so one species
activates another species the same with
the psychoactives one species activates
in other species to plug us in and so in
that it's like it's coming back to the
family and so I see the the shamanic
Renaissance that's happening with the
respect to indigenous cultures and
there's issues around commodification
and capitalism sort of commodifying
shamanic peak experiences but
essentially what's happening is
cleansing to reveal that we have this
sensitivity to connect to the signal
always being broadcast to be part of the
process of this collective ation that is
definitely coming up so we said at the
start this is fear there's this feeling
of feeling of like a dead end on
planetary civilization right that we've
we've hit the wall that we're facing
imminent financial collapse where
civilization Lee overextend humans are
not valued we're not valuing ourselves
we're we're a cancer threading
throughout both civilization and the
planet because we don't understand why
your original question why are we here
it's like the miracle of life so I was
in in Mexico down in the desert in the
Holy Land aware Acuto with the which
whole nations they have this pilgrimage
once a year so that the rich oles are
like one of the oldest Mesoamerican
nations in Mexico they retain the
traditions and the old ways we were
shooting episode two of shamans of the
global village calm
it wasn't just about taking this
medicine having a peak experience we
were like three days in the desert with
the the Murakami their medicine people
with men women and children who were
going to the land because again the role
of the shaman or the medicine person is
very arduous you're responsible for the
health and well-being of the community
and the community in the biome of the
lands you're the bridge between all the
interoperable parts of gaia and so we
would go to these holy spots where they
believe the first life on earth earth
formed and we would bless the water with
prayers and with candles and with
offerings and they did a sacrifice of a
lamb at this other temple spot you know
and you know blood is an original
sacrifice but then we eventually got
around to the peyote and to going out
onto the land and to hunting the peyote
with respect and with singing and with
the their songs back and to wooing and
allowing the land to allow us to receive
the peyote interest and then we didn't
just take it we did it in this ceremony
out there in the desert on the on the
earth with men women and children of the
village eating the peyote right it's
beautiful little three-year-old girl
with his machete knives just carving up
the peyote and and and what I saw in
them was this real understanding that
that indigenous people are poor but they
are so rich in life because they are
back on the earth and they're in the
earth and they're in ceremony of life
with the earth and they are receiving
that information and they train their
children from an early age to be part of
that community not to mollycoddle them
and keep them you know at the side
they're in there whether that's they're
doing everything they are lots are doing
and they're given a responsibility which
is the ability to respond which is what
it means to be human to be sovereign to
understand what you mean and to respond
and if you understand what you're in
right now it's a planetary scale
emergency and the emergency has the
potential for the emergence because
nature knows what it's doing there's a
process underway that cyclic can happens
over hundreds of thousands of the years
between the ice ages civilizations
flourish in very brief bandwidths of
within that life flourishes and we have
a very target window to evolve right and
then there's that possibility of
becoming something greater you know make
a bet to do so in concert with the earth
and the other species and yeah that's my
prayer that's my hope so if there's this
whole generation of shamanic activist
maybe or even psychedelic activists and
the psychedelic Renaissance and here in
San Francisco it's very much booming
there's so many meetup groups and
integration groups which is so needed
because we don't see it but that the
psychedelic a peak of the 60s came in a
very short amount of years and was very
vertically boom in their face but
there's been a slow drip where it's
bigger than it was in the 60s now it's
more distributed it's more embedded it's
more anchored there's elders and their
structure and there's dissemination into
the culture to bring it in slowly so the
psychedelic Renaissance is part of the
shamanic resurgence but it's the
medicalization thing where civilization
is gonna be fine you've got PTSD take
this MDMA or take some ketamine and go
back to work it's like that's great but
it's like the true potential of these
relationships with the shamanic
entheogens is to reveal essentially that
you are a divine being you are part of
the interconnected ecology of the planet
which is alive consciousness has birthed
you loves you and wants you to shine in
this miracle called life or you can go
back to work and microdose LSD anyway
there is still a movement within the
shamanic resurgence and the global
psychedelic Renaissance for activism for
this understanding that if we are going
to survive this emergency the original
tool is consciousness and you can you
can sort of like drop iron pallets into
the ocean and then the unforeseen
consequences of geoengineering are gonna
you know stuff up down the line because
we don't understand the interconnected
web if you take five dried grams of
magic mushrooms you're going to
understand the interconnected web as
Terence Mckenna used to famously say so
if we can marry the scientific paradigm
with this shamanic power
which are both sciences and both have
these older lineages and understand what
we're in then there's opportunity to as
we've seen with psychedelics from the
50s and 60s enhanced creativity think
outside the box but also reconnect to
our hearts reconnect to the stomach and
to the planetary biome reconnect to what
I got in Mexico on the peyote it was
actually quite gentle wasn't very
visionary for me I had about three
slices of the peyote when it was blessed
and offered by the Murakami but what I
really got was this remembrance that
like that vibration we talked about
before that it is always emanating it's
like a broadcast signal it's what they
think you know consciousness of the
brain is a receiver not just a
transmitter of consciousness that we're
receiving the signal of consciousness
itself from source into in which is
transmitting into potentially the Stars
the planets and the species which given
life in the crucible of the planet and
that within that there's a song it's
like a song it's like that vibrate it's
like the arm again or so when they
download the ucae rose and the songs
it's like there's a universal song which
is always being sung and all the species
are actually the notes in the song and
we've been silent for 10,000 years
waiting for the moment when the chorus
kicks in right and we remember and if
you've ever had a shamanic experience
there can be a lot of healing there can
be a lot of purging it can be hard work
but once you get beyond that it's
cleaning you out to realize you're the
vessel for the divine intelligence
manifesting on earth through this
miracle called life there is such joy
there is such understanding which
doesn't come from here it comes from
here or that you are part of something
greater and it is birthing you and you
are not alone you are part of the
Galactic family right so my hope is and
I coined this hashtag the other week
Galacta vism my hope is that you know as
this emergency unfolds on planet earth
we can marry all the pathways that are
needed to survive the emergency but it
comes down to consciousness it comes
down to can we know what we're in can we
know why we're here can we know what
these times really
and then can we use the scientific
technologies and our advanced
civilization in the very short amount of
time I have let we have left the
Murakami told me that essentially and
many indigenous communities and tribes
who work with shamanic medicines are
saying that the plant spirits are saying
on behalf of the earth it's like the
earth is not well the earth is sick big
changes are coming and not like
generations away like in this generation
and we're seeing it you know every every
other week we see another ice shall fall
off you know we see the the the methane
released we see the exponential growth
of all the prognostications of where
it's going increasing very quickly and
then we go what's happening with the
Oscars today we just go back we're in
denial so this is five stages of grief
right you have the the rage denial grief
acceptance those stages of accepting
change we are not accepting we are at
the end of civilization that's a great
thing it's not something to fear because
we are so embedded and so occupied with
this separation that we've made the
trauma of separation the plus we think
that this is normal it's only been ten
thousand years the dream time
consciousness is still out there the
planet is working to cleanse and heal
and open our full capacity the full
spectrum of consciousness to bring us
back into it to upgrade the species to
where we used to be in other world ages
to remember who and what we really are
yet we're like I don't want to I just
want my facebook feed right so on three
days in the desert with men women and
children on peyote connecting to the web
of life feeling the song of life being
broadcast feeling the heart open
grokking and understanding everything in
nature talking to me not a hallucination
right intuitively understanding you know
nature is always communicating to us and
I'm part of it and then I get back on
the bus and I go back to the city and
then I'm in the airports everyone is on
their phones and I'm like oh my god
planetary battery farm like zombie
apocalypse right we are there zombies
right
because we've forgotten and so as the
emergency start happening this the
metaphor that the frog in you chuck a
frog into a boiling pot of water it
jumps out if you put it in that in the
thing and slowly heat the water it just
adapts and it's like no it's okay there
goes another ice shelf I'll there's like
another thing happening over there
exponentiating is like that's a bit
scary Oh worst wildfire season in
recorded history highest temperatures in
the world in recorded history floods
worst floods in recorded history the
organism of Earth is trying to purge the
civilizational sickness of humanity
right and this is a good thing because
it's not sustainable and on the other
side it's potentially that reunification
with who and what we really are this is
just the facade so we used to be in
whatever originals called dream time
consciousness something happened we had
a fall which these biblical stories say
the fall from grace and we fell into
hierarchical linear time and that's part
of the cycle of the world ages right and
we built history and we've been scared
of nature and built things around us to
protect us and taken things and we
invented the future and and then start
to charge people forward and keep
separation from the tribe as well as
from the earth and there's just worse
and worse fractal disintegration of the
reciprocal relationship of life right
and so it's meant to end right and I'm
not saying when I'm not a doomsday I'm a
transformational list right I understand
what nature is saying it's like this is
just the clothes you wear right you were
born again and again and again and again
you are an emanation of me it's like
it's like when we drink coca-cola when
we kill a million microorganisms in our
gut right it's like the organism doesn't
die just the microorganisms that if they
think they're individual and separate
they're like oh I'm dead so many people
I know have shaman experience especially
five Meo understand that what the
ensured of connection is telling them
it's like this is not just you this is
like a base station to host your
consciousness and that if this goes that
consciousness goes back into the ocean
of consciousness all around so in the
sixth grade
species extinctions we've had as the
animals all died off and the plants and
everything like that the form the
physical form which nature has invested
so much energy to create that falls away
but the bioenergetic roots of the soul
inhabiting the form goes back into the
world soul and then it has a cusp where
it creates new species they've done nice
core samples in the Arctic where they
see and they can track in time when the
cosmic rays have hit when it's created
these chemical changes in the ice core
samples or what's happened on earth and
matched it to the evolutionary surges of
new species right it happens it's meant
to happen the old is meant to make way
from the new and when we fear letting go
this is the archetypal psychedelic
shamanic experience it's all about
letting go of your ego letting go of
your individuality and thinking that
you're just this right you're actually
that having this experience and when we
let go of that and reconnect it is
joyful it is miraculous and that our
whole indigenous understanding of
sacrifice is to make sacred that's the
Latin for sacrifice and to make sacred
means to come back to Pachamama to the
earth to understand that you are a nerve
ending of God in matter and an emanation
of the planetary biology and that it's
all ok it's a larger process underway
right
so I also came across a friend of mine
Maria in Mexico City on the way back
from the desert and she had this whole
beautiful riff about Ubuntu this you
know African ideology or operating
system for civilization how can I be
happy if you're not happy no it says I
am because we are and because we are ok
the Soviet I am Ron are you okay with us
concede because we are we can wrap it up
okay I am because we are because we are
all one because we're actually one
colony organism in the planetary biome
and that generation who is now striking
all across the world for climate change
and for the older generations not acting
for the denialists not just for climate
change but for civilization will
collapse that it's okay
system as it is it's like there's this
societal flashpoint happening from the
old and the new and there's the amiga
generation comes through that's got
nothing to lose who are going to inherit
a dead earth they when they connect to
the awareness of who and what they
really are because psychedelics and
entheogens and planetary medicines are
spreading especially through the younger
generations have the potential to be not
just activist but to be GLE activist to
know who and what they really are we
asked at the start of the show and then
to act on it and to demand not demand
change to be the change right but you
can't do it unless you find your Center
you can do it from in egoic sense and
you're out there thinking that's okay so
about thinking it's about feeling and
when you feel it the planetary emergency
is the transformational tipping point
and that's what we're living through and
it's going to come really soon sooner
than we think I don't know that but
that's what the indigenous people are
saying that's what the plant medicines
and spirits are saying and we're at this
cusp of transformation which is okay
because it's that's what it's about it's
like you go through puberty you don't
want it you love being a kid then all of
a sudden these biological changes happen
in the planetary organism and then you
come through the other side and like
this is great right so that's my hope
that we can be planetary activists
galactic activists that Galacta vism can
take root and start to blossom in the
human bloom across the planet
thank you
we need more of your streams of
consciousness to get out to the world so
let's see what we can do about that I
think we have his own show so yeah so
the show with shamans in the global
village calm you've just done two
episodes now this one with the bufo
alvarius toad and there's one which
we've just shot and won't be out till
the end of the year with the the peyote
and the Murakami the Huichol nation I do
lead ayahuasca retreats once a year down
to Peru I have one coming up June 22nd
for 10 days
it's aya aya - awakenings calm and I do
talks like this and we take ayahuasca
and we work with a shaman Percy Garcia
Lozano and I know two people I love to
share my wisdom but also to be in this
space with people and to figure out how
I can help them so as a shamanic
facilitator I do work with the bullfrog
various medicine in Mexico and with the
Peru with ayahuasca and I believe that
that hands-on front edge of
consciousness is where I renew my
relationship to spirit and to assist
people in finding that within themselves
you can find my website at Rocco's am
calm I love you all thank you yeah the
links in the bio for everything and
there's a just like you know might one
of the things that I aim to do is to is
to be able to synthesize those because
of the brilliance of the people that get
that we get the honor of having come sit
here and then teach and from your stream
of consciousness that just being here
together with everything that has
manifested on earth in this womb it's
just such a blessing and it's so divine
and each one of us is so divine and then
what we've forgotten because of the
grooving of what's happened since the
Industrial Revolution even prior to that
we talk about this a lot the show's
called simulation we talk about what
would it be like if we would just have
slowed down when there were just a
million ten million of us and we just
slowed down and acted more of blending
that spirit with that science at a
slower more gentle rate and then we
could have had none of these ailments
and malevolence but it's also part of
the challenge is to be able to get
through what we have as it's perfect
because all in control we keep thinking
all we did something wrong history we
did this wrong we [ __ ] up the planet
it's like yes and there's larger forces
at work of why this is all happening and
it's like it's like you know the human
species this is Candida bloom and it's
it will come down again you've got to
reduce it so that it's a planet is
having this bloom of humans which is out
of control
it will regulate because it is a living
organism all is one always one and love
is all there is Rach we are very very
grateful for your work and we just we
want to see more people around the world
talking about what you're teaching and
and let's do that let's do that everyone
everyone thank you so much for tuning
Iraq thanks for coming on to the show
again this has been you know such an
honor
pleasure blessing come to Peru with me I
need to get butts down there to will to
do episodes with the shamanic leaders
I'll introduce you um did that would not
mind blowing this is the thing to listen
to the ancestors and to listen to the
indigenous people they're all crying
after people to listen to them and they
made me tea
- yes that yes yes exactly that's what
you're doing um and hopefully we can as
well everyone thank you for tuning in we
would love to hear from you let us know
your thoughts in the comments below we
would love for you to continue talking
about this with other people go and talk
more about what this is like uh
Ron thank you for producing and
directing we love you so much thank you
thank you check out the links in the bio
Toliver axe work also go and build the
future everyone support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in that
are around you that are spreading really
powerful messages our links are below
thank you much love and we will see you
soon everyone
[Applause]
[Music]